now there was a question and I can't
remember if I've assigned it so people
who finished the exercise please tell me
if you did there was a question that
looked like this y equals x cubed minus
1 you had to find the derivative of this
which of course we can all just stay
which is is a reading about yeah I can't
even if you haven't done this question
yet that's okay where I'm gonna take a
bit of a shortcut to get through here
they then say okay take this thing and
rearrange it to the Exeter subject okay
now we could do that at length but I'm
just going to go straight to or not
because I've written it down just here
okay really doesn't take that much
you've got this okay so all I've done is
move the constant and I've adjusted the
power and then this I can now
differentiate the other way around right
instead of differentiating Y with
respect to X I could differentiate X
with respect to Y so I'll switch to our
which variable is which at least in
terms of the algebra of the equation
okay so on this I can work out DX or dy
it's a simple chain rule okay what's
gonna happen third comes out the front
most one power decreases by one watch
for that and then I'm multiplied by the
derivative of the inside because it's
tuned what so in this case that doesn't
have an effect all right that's nice
that's fine then when you look at this
though I kind of know what Y is like I
started this with a definition for y
okay it's kind of weird to leave things
in terms of Y this looks a little bit
awkward so I don't have to stop there
right I can actually say I'll do it over
here since Y is defined as X cubed minus
one this backwards derivative like this
backwards dude I can go further with it
I can substitute it out and get
something that's a little more familiar
to me okay and I'll notice a path what
what happens
why of course is X cube minus one don't
skip the substitution
we've been pinned by that reason we
can't leave okay once I have a look at
that what's happening
brackets stuff kettles that's the nice
and then I can do one more thing
index laws what's gonna happen I
multiply these two together right so
this is one-third X to the minus two I
can just rearrange they get a little
more familiar because a negative tower
of course means it goes on the
denominator doesn't it
okay now that should make you suspicious
right because I did this and then I did
this and if you see you recognize me
like wait I must feel slightly ripped
off I did all of this calculus but in
fact all I needed to do was to turn this
upside down now please note this this is
the important result right there for dy
on DX times DX on dy right or I could
stand it I could equally state it like
this that what derivative is the
reciprocal of the other one this is
actually really really important okay
and it's kind of strange it's a stranger
than you might expect because what this
is showing is deep deal DX right like
this thing this is an operator this
means do something to something else
right just like sign is and log is and
all those other things right but we've
written it as a fraction now what this
is telling us is that even though it's
an operator it behaves just like a
regular fraction and we've kind of been
taking advantage of this and chain rule
already right when we've been doing
stuff like this
do I on do you times do you on yes we've
just been treating to you as an actual
number and then canceling right and not
noticing that do is a lot of number it's
this really infinitesimally small thing
that like how does it behave it's be
like infinity in fact it's a lot like
infinity and we know we can't just throw
anything around like any regular no but
for instance you can do things like this
too right that's not a regular number
you can do things like
to infinity where you can do things like
this through movies right
depending on the infinity you're looking
at so infinity is not a normal number
you can't do normal things to it but
this guy these infinitesimally you can
now we're gonna take advantage of that
with the inverse functions because when
you did this basically what I was doing
is why I regularly do when I'm trying to
find an inverse okay when I'm trying to
find a new bus so all of this all this
label it let's call this the original
function okay this is the original
function okay so on my original function
I haven't defined why I have it to find
dy/dx and I have it to find DX and dy
everything that we've just written on
the board only relates to that function
okay now let's talk about its inverse
that it's inverse okay I've already done
all the legwork I need to know what the
inverse function is what is these
inverse function of this particular unit
on the board it's this guy with one
crucial difference I've switched the
inputs the outputs of switch the X in
the wire right so I can say for the
inverse and only for the inverse Y is
not to find like that Y is to find like
this okay this is a new function so new
rules are in operation right now have a
look at this guy here right this is DX 1
dy or the original function so how do I
take this and use it over here
well just like I did for this I have to
swap everything right that's what it
means is to do the inverse so therefore
I'm going to take this DX on DeWine and
I'm going to make a statement about this
dy and DX not to be confused with this
dy DX right this one's in the original
world and this is in my inverse world
okay so everything is switched around
it's just
let's gotta write one on three
why right everything is switched around
okay
but of course I know what why is why is
this guy right so this is one on three X
plus 1 to the power I thought right so I
scram I'm 2/3 see Dez it's that square
okay now just look at this for a second
this is in a bit but we need form right
I'm going to write it in a form and I
show you the connection of the wall
where did that come up yeah we got this
from chain rule right general but we
didn't invoke chain rule this time I
invoke the fact that hey I know how this
function works and therefore I know how
the inverse function will behave does
that make sense so I kind of skipped the
chain rule path now in this case because
it's a simple example
right so when they gave you it's like
well I could have easily have just
looked at this and then differentiated
by chain rule that was not complicated
okay but when you start to put
Exponential's and logs and sine to ten
it takes out all the trigonometry in
there it starts to become very
advantageous to try and get away you
from chain rule because it gets a lot
messier than just two or three lines
okay
so therefore what's my conclusion what's
the property on going forth okay if you
have a function and you can work out its
derivative right if it's easy to
differentiate then all you need to do
you can write this one with me to find
the derivative on the inverse
you're gonna do two things okay to get
from this guy which is easy to find
right off the original function how do I
turn this into this
what things did I do first thing before
I went to the inverse idea is I took it
and I just turned it upside down right I
did not in fact what do I own DX I
wanted this guy to X on UI right so
firstly I take the reciprocal the reason
I took the reciprocal is because I want
the one where the X's and Y's are in the
reverse position from what I want
because that's what investors are with
the X and the y in the reverse positions
okay so then here you can either say as
reverse the positions of x and y or swap
the inputs and outputs the XS and the
Y's I'm going to say inputs and outputs
because they might not be X's and Y's it
could be ours or T's or theaters or
anything like that but we just want to
swap it that's all in the investments
okay
then lastly and this is kind of optional
so we're just not on it if it is
relevant if it helps you with the
particular question at hand at this
point here I've done these two steps I
took the reciprocal look it's upside
down right and then I swap the influence
in afterwards
see there's why there it's not an X
anymore I can't go to this step what is
this step what am i doing yeah I'm
substituting in beyond the new function
the inverse right right
so if appropriate or if helpful
substitute in
the invest function because that would
put everything in terms of your
independent variable which is the way
things usually are okay okay
like I said there are some there's some
weed ways to use this and you'll see
them in 1a in the questions that I have
no sign okay one last one we looked at
increasing decreasing the derivative now
we can look at symmetry so we're talking
about functions right here we have all
right to take the reciprocal I suppose
you could take off the drew that's what
welcome to any of the original
derivative right which is that step
which skips the chain rule part for you
huh tada right so if you want to avoid
that's the way that you do it